when a bag is made from a billboard it
has a story its creative its bold every
bag is giving back and it's being
eco-friendly I was working advertising
and I saw that all the billboards that
were going up in essence we're going to
the landfill most people don't know that
billboards are made of vinyl and it can
be turned into something else and so
let's create a business that's solely
based on billboards on any given month
we get close to around 10,000 pounds of
billboards that we turn into product
once that billboard goes up it's usually
up for a period of about 4 weeks is what
a typical campaign is on the street for
its then shipped to our facility here we
sort it we cut it and send it to the
manufacturer or where they do the final
sewing and cleaning of the product we're
able to take a billboard that had one
purpose and then reuse it to make
something else my brother myself are
both huge surfers and we kind of felt
like the sort of community loves bright
colors and billboard vinyl is actually
very durable it's a thick material it's
waterproof its milder proof so it's
actually the perfect material for a
surfboard back after that we spent in
two backpacks duffle bags wallets fanny
packs hip packs snowboard bags every
products different every products
one-of-a-kind each piece that we make is
unlike anything before it
our playground for all of us is based in
the environment whether it's the
mountains the rivers the the ocean it's
something that we in essence have a
responsibility to maintain and sustain